hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now
starting off as we did in last one I've
got a few new names to add to my wall
the first one is Luke Kay who said waits
in hope that mark will encounter the sea
emperor and I don't know what the sea
emperor is so holy crap is that a new
creature there was that added to the
game I have no idea but it sounds
terrifying
the next one goes to Stefan RG which who
said hahaha
the [ __ ] duck is going deep and that
just made me laugh and then Ernesto
Cortez so I'm just gonna put Ernesto I'm
sad don't worry mark take your time with
the game we appreciate what you do for
us and IRA preciate that because I love
to take my time with this game because
there's a lot of exploration to be done
I mean I'm gonna put the farming
off-camera
always but I just there's something very
peaceful and terrifying about the game
when you go into the ocean because of
how well crafted it is how well rounded
it is the sound effects all the
different like aspects of the game come
together to make a very interesting
that's not very far away interesting
experience before I go there I'm gonna
repair my doodad no I'm gonna repair my
doodad i'ma repair the [ __ ] a duck we're
gonna figure out what the hell this
landmass is because when I here landmass
I think of Island now this better
actually be something and not a whole
lot of nothing okay it's going off into
a direction that I've never been before
is it really Wow okay I'm hip I'm
happening I'm doing it I'm ready to do
is it I'm ready to see what the hell
this is
could it have really been so close if
I'd I've gone in this direction before
but deep underwater I never bothered to
look up I mean I'm a little
oh my god what the hell that was there
the whole time what the hell is that
where'd that come from was that just not
gonna appear unless I found why wait is
that an observatory already on there
what is with this what are you are you
oh my god how did I miss this it's huge
it's covered in brine
it's got floaties ball sacks it's
pulsating
it's got pulsating floaty ball sacks
that disappear when you're not looking
oh my god holy crap what the buck [ __ ] a
duck
landing the [ __ ] duck has landed I
don't know if I'm gonna be able to get
it off the dirt there hopefully I can
push it there we go
you'll be free I'll be back god it's
beautiful
whoa cool orange mushroom yes I will
scan you dink and I swear that's an
observatory on there why is there an
observatory on the top of the mountain
peak and how do I get up there I mean
it's just swimming underwater I'm not
used to this climbing stuff I haven't
used my legs in weeks months even all of
my muscles have atrophied are about to
fall off my bones whoa whoa wait whoa
Cyclops pressure compensator that is the
depth module for the Cyclops so that
that particular thing that is a little
odd that particular thing that I just
scanned is gonna allow my Cyclops to go
down deeper under water purple rattle I
don't know what that means I don't know
what scanning this is all about okay
it's nothing it's green and makes me
vibrate old cooked it's not that old
gosh
all right then can I get a sample of
this orange mushrooms it's big why is it
big I've been asked that many times
before shut up everybody okay this is
something I can do
it's nothing I can see the aurora from
here that's so weird you think I would
have noticed this giant freaking Island
here long long ago hey what's the
climbing mechanics of this game Oh
Nikes I don't know if there's any fall
damage to be had but I don't want to
experience it if it's true well that's
so pretty oh my god I want to dive into
it but I don't want to lose my god no
choice here we go ah get oh that was
cool
oh that's so cool oh my god this is
amazing
okay so I switch you with what you got
going on there I don't know if that's
supposed to be happening okay so I'm
going to try to get to one of the
observatories I will be right back
unless I find something worth finding
and then you guys will see it and me
probably screaming in fear from it
because I'm screaming in fear of
everything
purple Vaz plant purple Vaz plant why am
i filling up my inventory with giant
seeds that I hello hang on whoa that Wow
that is a very old habitat now who was
marvel melon can I eat that I can't eat
that oh I can eat that what the heck
okay I'm gonna drop the mushroom spore
in the I'm gonna drop these because
there's plenty of them around especially
the pink flower ones but I'm gonna keep
these marble melon because that that was
okay though apparently those are a
mystery but that was
yeah I could farm these are here huge I
shouldn't have picked them up oh my god
oh that's so cool key you stay there
this is a better source of food than
I've ever had oh my god hello
this chief executive officer of the
Torrance place corporation the crew and
I were marooned here five weeks ago our
ship was struck by a projectile of
unknown origin three of us left we
constructed a habitat using materials
reclaimed from the ship we survived by
cultivating indigenous flora the
biochemistry imprint I commissioned for
my son has already paid for itself
he has grown enough food to last us a
month
sounds familiar sounds like exactly what
I was here now I fear for our safety a
mercenary I hired for the journey has
grown increasingly disturbed since
losing her mate in the crash she insists
we abandoned the site and established a
deep ocean base now why would that be
that's what I did against my better
judgment I have greed we will come with
her okay
please come for us nighttime approach I
don't think that was part of the message
but does that mean that they they have
another hidden base somewhere
underground because that are underwater
because that would be ridiculous and
amazing I would be so down for that and
oh my god it's nighttime I can't even
see a goddamn thing see if we can use
this Oh got a lot creepier in the middle
of the night it was a very lovely lovely
lovely lovely lovely Island now it's
spooky
my elbows don't bend down I can't flex
my arms ninety degrees downward it would
be too painful there's a path up this
mountain which guy can only assume it's
gonna lead to another observational base
somewhere around here or it's gonna
allow me to plummet to my death what are
the other I'm up for anything tonight
said I can't tell if there's a gap there
is a gap if I walked into that it would
be my doom
goddammit night what are you hello
that's different
well that wasn't there but that is
Earth's moon you can't fool me
developers that is literally Earth's
moon why is that there I've never ever
ever seen that before in this game ever
this is the first time you and I have
ever spoken moon and this is where the
complete ocean insanity takes hold and I
lose my goddamn mind almost there almost
hello we made it yes okay hello ah more
plants more food marbled melon I don't
know how to grow you myself but whoa
hello why do I have a scannable skin
chair really skin chair okay I'm taking
your word for this one I don't know what
happened here was there a murder or
something starship chair blueprint I'm
in the ocean is beds not for night okay
anyway desk I didn't know that I could
scan these okay so that was good but
what I'm not seeing here I'm not seeing
is any sort of spotlight is any sort of
other audio log or something like that
to explain what the hell happened here
and why did someone set up an
observation area on the top of this
mountain this seems obtuse and difficult
I mean it's a great view don't get me
wrong it's a fantastic view and I want
to get to the other mountain but I mean
just the loneliness got to people and
they had to build a base up here just to
try to feel know just try to feel normal
I do not know if there's fall damage but
I have a funny feeling that I'm gonna
break my legs okay nevermind I'm gonna
be okay everything's fine everything's
fine everything's good everything's good
okay back to the other one without dying
preferably but that does explain a lot
of things and I would be willing to bet
that somewhere somewhere in the deepest
farthest reaches of the ocean
there is a base oh god there is a base
where these people left following the
leadership of the mercenary who lost her
mate you know I don't know why I
referred to her partner as mate it's a
little little odd vernacular for hoomans
cuz we don't usually call him that but
whatever it's fine
oh hello thank you I could have been on
top of the world there apparently still
can oh boy that is a precarious thing
makes me launch in the air
whoa okay let's not let's not tumble
head over heels off the edge of the
island just yet
but there is something else over there
dad oh that's a bird Wow
I can literally see forever up here that
is nuts oh my goodness Wow
I mean Wow Wow okay
anyway back into the building where we
need to find something disinfected water
anything else Wow holy crap hanging
fruit that sounds amazing can I make one
of these if I plant one of these inside
my base can I do this sounds so cool I
mean obviously it's just flora and fauna
but where can I get this stuff from my
base I mean I could make a base on this
island I could I could make a base and
this could be an infinite old it's still
good that's what I get from picking it
yeah good enough decomposed I've got to
drop these I'm just gonna leave these
here there's gonna spoil and ruin the
entire plan here man but this is good
this is so good and there's like an
infinite source of food so long as that
actually does regrow this is very good
okay so that's all the time that I got
for this episode Oh God
we're fine everything's fine so thank
you everybody so much for joining me in
the next episode I'm gonna make a base
on this island because this is just too
good to pass up there is so much cool
stuff here to explore and it
adds a completely different dynamic and
it appeals to me as a woman that I want
to put my feet on solid land there might
even be like a cave in here because
there was a way to get down to that
swimming pool in the swimming pool
that's my swimming pool in my backyard
or my private island where my friends
are fish and plant anyway so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you
[Music]